e o que é convidar vocês para o
exercício de imaginação
e o que é que se pudesse imaginar comigo
o mundo onde a gente já tem todo recurso
todo capital e toda a tecnologia
necessária para resolver quaisquer
problemas da nossa humanidade imagina
comigo o mundo a gente pode criar robôs
feito de forma híbrida um células-tronco
para que ataca indiretamente elas
descansa ou até mesmo va esses mesmos
robôs para coletar micro plástico no
oceano Pensa num mundo em que a gente
consegue criar concreto que tem o poder
de se auto regenerar e ao mesmo tempo em
dia desse alto regenera ele consegue
capturar toxinas do ar em nosso entorno
o mundo onde a gente consegue cultivar
alimento feição de plantas em
laboratório e esses mesmos alimentos são
feitos de forma automatizada para cada
um dos veniais de cada pessoa para que
possa aumentar de forma expressiva não
só saúde e bem-estar mas também a
longevidade
a consome esse tipo de alimento imagina
só mundo a gente pode usar a tecnologia
de impressão 3D para imprimir casas
inteiras com menos de $5000 que são
impressas em menos de 24 horas
imaginamos um mundo em que a gente já
tem tecnologia para dessalinizar a água
do mar e fazer com que a água chegue no
meio de desertas e criar plantações onde
a gente nunca imaginou que poderia ter
plantações inteiras imaginação mundo
onde a gente já tem tecnologia
suficiente para conseguir criar vacinas
para uma das maiores poderios de nossa
história e isso tudo foi feito em menos
de 12 meses já contando com aprovação de
órgãos internacionais de supervisão para
que a vacina cheguem de forma segura na
nossa população
a imaginação mundo a gente tem já
aparelhos cabe dentro do nosso bolso e
que a gente pode com um talks encontrar
quaisquer tipos de informação quaisquer
tipo de conhecimento que nos ajudem a
nos comunicar a resolver problemas
locais com preços cada vez mais
acessíveis Hoje em Dia com menos de um
real que o dia imagina o mundo o link
vai ter plataformas onde a gente pode
certa forma mais tocar todo o
conhecimento do planeta para que
quaisquer pessoas em quaisquer lugares
do nosso mundo consiga resolver os
problemas locais que os a solo atento
tem em alguns tocs olhando por esse
mesmo aparelho que estava no bolso delas
eu ia te perguntar como que você sente
quando eu te conto desse mundo eu
imagino que assim como eu você também
sente um otimismo um sentimento de
Orgulho e um sentimento que nenhum
desafio pode ser páreo para nossa
humanidade né
e ao mesmo tempo eu queria te convidar
para um segundo exercício de imaginação
eu queria imaginar um mundo onde dez
porcento da população Global a vivendo
com menos de um ponto 9 dólares por dia
quer dizer que quase um milhão de
pessoas estão vivendo com cerca de dez
doze raios por dia e quando eu falo
viver é para comer para se vestir para
ser educado para sonhar para ter lazer o
mundo em que países como Brasil vão ter
nos próximos anos cerca de 100 milhões
de pessoas sofrendo algum tipo de
insegurança alimentar o mundo em que a
gente tem 700 milhões de jovens e nem
trabalham nem estudam daqueles jovens
que estão estudando e trabalhando eles
estão ganhando cerca de 1.5 dólares por
dia
Eu imagino um mundo onde praticamente
metade da nossa população rural
quem não sabe que lavar as mãos pode
prevenir doenças simples e que aumentam
a sua qualidade de vida Essas atividades
e mesmo que elas soubessem que lavar as
mãos nos ajudam a prevenir essas doenças
muitas vezes essas mesmas comunidades e
não vão ter acesso a água limpa e o
sabão qualquer outro título a química o
que os ajudem a prevenir essas doenças
imagina mundo onde uma em cada cinco
crianças não vão conseguir chegar na
escola uma em cada três pessoas não vai
ter acesso a água potável não tô falando
de vinho cerveja suco órgão do tipo
quando de água potável que a gente
precisa para sobreviver imagina aqui
nesse mesmo planeta praticamente metade
da população não vai ter acesso a nenhum
tipo de esgoto e obviamente que não ter
acesso não tipo de esgoto nesse mesmo
mundo a gente tem praticamente 800
crianças morrendo
Bom dia de diarreia ou doenças parecidas
lembra que quando cai no avião de 150
agentes pessoas a gente tem comoção
Nacional a gente reflete sobre a vida
etc é como se quatro Avenidas inteiros
caíssem todos os dias só com crianças
por conta diferenças tão simples de
prevenir contra diarreia como você se
sente agora imaginando esse mundo acho
que aquele sentimento de orgulho que eu
teísmo de acreditar que tudo é possível
começa a ser substituído por aperto no
peito um nó na garganta e um sentimento
de não mais tão utilismo depois fazer
esse exercício de imaginação eu imagino
que a gente fica se perguntando Será que
é possível que esses dois mundos sejam
mesmo lugar
Hum será que é possível que um planeta
onde a gente tem coisas tão incríveis
impulsionados pela famosa a quarta
Revolução Industrial também tenha ainda
problemas tão básicos e que traga tanta
desigualdade ao nosso lado e eu não tô
falando de Dois Mundos que já existiram
ou que ainda não existia tô falando de
Dois Mundos que conseguem coexistir
agora no presente a gente vive no mundo
que é muito paradoxal a gente ao mesmo
tempo que nunca teve tanta informação
tanto a tecnologia tanto recurso para
resolver quaisquer problemas da nossa
unidade a gente talvez nunca sentiu que
a gente tá tão distante tão desigual tão
desacreditado como que é possível 500
empresas do ranking da Forbes Global
terem lucro quase metade do que a gente
precisa para resolver toda agenda da
e essa 169 metros para financiar que
pelo menos metade de toda a pobreza no
planeta toda desigualdade toda a falta
de acesso à água e etc fosse fechada o
lucro de uma não tô falando de todo
recurso que foi gerada tô falando de
lucro dessas empresas de 500 empresas
somente como que é possível a gente
dizendo um planeta em que após uma das
grandes pandemias as humanidade os
milionários fiquem mais ciclos e as
pessoas no geral fiquem mais pobres
E como que é possível um por cento da
população global sedona de quase
cinquenta por cento de toda a renda de
nosso planeta no Brasil um por cento da
população a dona de quase quarenta por
cento da renda dos países para te ajudar
a entender melhor do que é isso é como
se uma cidade com a população de
Curitiba tivesse a mesma renda do que
toda a população presente no norte
nordeste centro-oeste e Sul é esse
paradoxo que eu tô falando é esse
paradoxo que precisa ser resolvido Eu
sonho com um futuro em que nós seres
humanos a gente teve a coragem de
resolver esse paradoxo a gente parou de
acreditar que falta recurso que falta
capital falta tecnologia e a gente teve
coragem de começar a servir organizações
que constroem pontes e resolvem de fato
os problemas a sociedade
a dificuldade de acesso e oportunidades
Mais emotivas Sonhar acreditar que é
possível esse mundo existir e um dono
desse paradoxo derreteu são organizações
empreendedores que a gente já consegue
encontrar hoje em dia hoje nesse mundo
que você já vivi já existe empreendedor
já existe investidor que tem coragem de
manifestar esse futuro existe
empreendedor que era especialista em
fábricas multinacionais aprendeu tudo de
como criar processo de como criar
tecnologias que geravam mais eficiência
na sua empresa e resolveu largar sua
fábrica multinacional para ensinar a
cooperativa de catadores de lixo até
esse padrão de multinacional e agora ele
está criando modelos de franquias
sociais que conseguem garantir que
outras cooperativas de lixo no Brasil
inteiro possam e mais citado mais lixo
seja reciclado
e tem um altíssima eficiência muito
melhores resultados como padrão de
multinacional podemos catador de lixo
agora padrão de multinacional por conta
desse tipo de empreendedor e Graça A
esse empreendedor a gente tá vendo cada
vez mais cooperativas poderiam
distribuir capital atribuir valor não
sofre eles mesmos mas também para a
sociedade quanto mais esse empreendedor
de certo mas poderia ter seguido Mais
Capital distribuído mais lixo é
reciclada e o mais legal de pensar é que
esse empreendedor ele tem uma família
ele é feliz ele mora numa boa casa e não
tem feito falta para ele uma Ferrari ou
uma mansão cheia de quatro fasios esse
empreendedor ele conseguiu redefinir o
que é sucesso ele conseguiu dar sentido
ao lucro e prosperar o propósito de
todos aqueles que estão lutando dele me
inspira acreditar também que mercado
financeiro também pode impulsionar por
o impacto acidental e gerar riqueza para
além da financeira quando ele Foca no
longo prazo e foca de forma responsável
mercado financeiro química vezes é
enxergado como aquilo que traz maior
desigualdade pode ser exatamente tem que
catalisa a transformação social que a
gente precisa a me inspirar acreditar
que existem já empreendedores e
investidores criando mecanismos de
financiamento para classes b e que mora
em condições insalubres a terem uma
moradia mais digna criaram por exemplo
um projeto piloto em que foi captado
cinco milhões de reais e permite a
realização de praticamente oito mil
reformas nos próximos anos e que gera
benefícios para mais de 32 mil pessoas e
o mais legal é que ao propor e ter a
coragem de propor para investidores só
começassem a receber seus retornos a
partir do sexto ano aqueles cinco reais
foram usados para pagar mais se formas e
quase multiplicadas para 40 milhões de
reais
as moradias que poderão ser reformadas e
quando fazem isso geram uma série de
resultados e gira economia local gerando
renda dos pedreiros gerando benefícios
para todos aqueles envolvidos na cadeia
de valor quanto mais investidores
começam a acreditar nesse tipo de
instrumento pelo capital nesse tipo de
título mais pessoas começa a ter acesso
a crédito começa a ter uma moradia mais
digna a economia local dessa comunidade
começa a diria mais ser mais movimentada
e o benefício acaba sendo para todos
nessa nova narrativa de sucesso a que a
gente precisa focar Que mundo que você
quer criar aquele em que serve
organizações que mesmo que possuem
soluções tecnológicas incríveis acabam
por concentrar mais poder mais capital
prioriza o resultado financeiro a
Qualquer Custo ou será que dá para você
ter coragem de acreditar e servir e
negócio sempre
O que é o mesmo tempo em que conseguem
gerar lucro suficiente também consegue
resolver os problemas da sociedade
distribuir valor sib capital para todos
aqueles que estão envolvidos diminuindo
esse paradoxo que tanto nos assola
inspira acreditar que é possível a gente
colocar tecnologias israelense ao
serviço de algo maior me inspira a
acreditar que é possível se um dia a
gente ter um Spotify em que os
acionistas são os artistas e a gente
consegue distribuir mais valor para
todos a gente pode ter plataformas de
delivery de comida que quanto mais
crescem mais lucro Mas elas acabam com a
fome no mundo a gente conseguir entender
que existem plataformas de educação que
podem servir como Libertadores de
conhecimento e quanto mais elas ganham
dinheiro elas também mais se vou vir os
talentos que existem escondidos em cada
um de nós parar para pensar que é sim
possível a gente criar Plata
e exponenciais de transporte e que a
gente tem os motoristas como acionistas
por exemplo e quando essa empresa começa
a criar a tecnologia que substitui os
motoristas na verdade gente vai entender
que são investimentos que trazem
aposentadoria desses mesmos que também
são acionistas e eu poderia ficar horas
aqui sonhando uma ficção social e
inspire todos a criarmos as pontes três
Paradox a gente precisa acreditar que é
possível a gente falar de negócios sem
necessidade de falar que são negócios
conscientes simplesmente negócios já
partindo do princípio que ele sente vão
trazer valor para todos que a gente vai
poder falar de investimentos sem focar
nos investimentos SG Mas sabendo que
aqueles investidores que mais possuem
capital podem ser os catalisadores da
grande mudança ao mesmo tempo que eles
também têm lucros suficientes para si
próprios eu espero que um dia a gente
possa parar de sonhar com
é paradoxal que a gente começa na
verdade a ter orgulho de um presente em
que esse paradoxo vira pobreza que vai
ser história e que a gente só vai
conseguir aprender sobre ela e museus